[Applaudissements]
on saura tout sur un an
ce soir je vais vous parler de
réservation et aménagement concerté des
rivières combat toi je vais pas vous
perdre en théorie
j'ai plutôt comparer une expérience
personnelle c'est un damné polynésie
vous passer de temps dans la lignée moi
je suis arrivé il ya 20 ans ici on voit
les germes et sur lequel tu as tu étais
et je me suis installé je travaille ici
et là j'ai eu la chance
en quelques secondes le travail de
l'équipe
il a ajouté je vais partager un petit
peu d'expérience personnes avant de
continuer donc je vais vous expliquer ma
vision des monédières qu'il expliquait
ainsi que la complexité de ses limites
et sont souvent atteints meeting on a
beau les verts particulière son nom des
balles et 13 encaissés les semoirs pose
problème sur les continents on avalise
n'yat-il sont plus vite sur des vallées
qui font plusieurs dizaines kilomètres
de large
ici c'est pas ça vous verrez quand je
parle de millières je vais en fait
beaucoup parler ballet ce qui est
impossible à tahiti de faire la
différence entre laisser le sujet donc
ici je vous en ai poteaux qu'il venait
d'apporter nos plus importantes des prix
me traiter de tels outils
j'ai passé beaucoup d'années pour faire
plein de choses différentes mais une
partie de la population qui va les
vêtements sinon rien chercher ça
m'aurait peut être chercher son art
sinon on ne pense pas à ça
il est encore aussi aujourd'hui entre
les ai beaucoup de gens psg chez brecht
et minérales et petit alain qu'on allait
s'en prend à la logique est une
quelquefois des envies
c'est aussi un oral de récréation pour
drainer sur mac nous sommes tous deux
dit parce que c'est anormal on va
pouvoir communier avec la nature
ce bénévole et toujours
un globe aussi j'appelle un grand stade
à ciel ouvert depuis des années on va se
croiser à déballer de plus en plus de
gens qui marchent ou courent qui font du
vélo
ils formaient un député de tendu et
électrique qui va le mikado assume
et puis il ya de plus en plus de
compétitions qui sont organisés on sait
danser mieux qui draine énormément de
personnes
et puis un élément important qui est la
partie touristique découvert aux
prestataires touristiques de renommée
grand mère estime rappelle encore de nom
des éditeurs a mis à dos tout ça c'est
pas 500 me poser les problèmes et
s'entraîner forcément unification
d'aller sur la liberté a tapé doh les
contacts des élections entre 300 et 500
venus le jour j -p
ils sont très très longtemps et déploré
les européens et ses muses ont été
rapidement abandonné la végétation a
repris ses droits
donc il ya encore des centaines des
milliers au logis qui sont en cash et de
révéler ce qui peut d'un côté et
préserver ce qu'il peut aussi l inverse
faire qui sait si dense perdre ce que la
végétation va finir par le poteau de
phare et ap et puis une photo de
l'association a les mots avec qui j'ai
passé beaucoup de temps ces vingt
dernières années avec qui vous
travaillez arimany culture polynésienne
archéologie ils sont devenus un petit
peu un phare culturel dans cette année
sur tahiti soutien aux abonnés mobiles
il faut tout bleu de la thème les jeunes
doctorants qui vient d'être diplômée
avec une étude vitesse sur les oreilles
en polynésie travailler sur les rivières
devenir une experte reconnue pacifique
tout ça pour montrer que c'est encore de
recherche scientifique à mener
nous irons en fonction c'est saison qui
sont très très complexe à la rivière
communique avec la mer ou des amis qui
d'époque sont donnés de la mer et c'est
cette centrale voilà vous et nice car à
qui vous donnez moi un homme très très
important d'intervenants qui viennent au
manoir faire des choses mais justement
très différentes
une dernière partie qui est important
qu'ils aient la partie industrielle la
partie technique utilisée et j'étais moi
je suis ingénieur de formation sur nos
tables 81% des blogs est consommée en
polynésie on se résigne donc d'aller
s'asseoir captage direct soit par les
débits d'eau de l'année il ya un vrai
enjeu de la population important et puis
une autre activité complémentaire
importante c'est une renault tricité par
un tiers de l'électricité produite sur
l'île de tahiti est d'origine électrique
donc prend sa source dans les vallées
alors c'est la partie a grandement
exposées
maintenant je vous êtes là c'est un
petit peu un décor si vous parlez mon
expérience personnelle et le talent
difficultés de tous ces intervenants à
se retrouver au même endroit si les deux
se sont renversés touré et point commune
par l'ennemi l'organe dans les vallées
tour des sujets valait quand j'ai croisé
des politiques c'est quoi ces détails
des fonctionnaires la préservation du
développement des procédés industriels
s'est croisé des autoneiges prestataires
de services et des baladeurs des
associations culturelles nation sportive
énormément et j'ai eu l'occasion de
travailler sur d une dizaine d'années au
sein du comité de suivi de la vallée de
la papenoo
on était une vingtaine à se réunir
au sujet de la vallée sa préservation
c'est une expérience humaine extrêmement
enrichissante
de par ses différences culturelles et
les différences entre nous j'ai un
ingénieur au va et à côté de moi j'avais
dvd grande allemande est ce que c'est
j'ai découvert manifestement au même
endroit dans la vallée perdue de choses
au point
un second vol est foncièrement différent
est ce qu'on a envie de faire avaler au
maire il peut sembler très très
différent si on sait qu arnaud s'écoute
et se respecte est d'apprendre à englos
fonctionnement intellectuel de l'autre
on peut passer au dessus de tout ça et
sortir de l'immobilisme
parce que le pire à mon ami c'est
l'immobilisme ne se passe rien ou à
soutenir de préservation était rien et
ne rien faire dans le dahlia ce n'est
pas la préserver
c'est année c'est faire face toute seule
à tous les dangers limogeage touré et
non pas être en possibilités de l'aîné
de mesure et transmises par ce scénario
mais comme les shannon rempel en mode
saas alors ces nombreuses séances à ses
parents un quart d'heure ça se fait en
20 minutes mais sur sap et même les
quelques années on est arrivés les et en
faisant tous un pas vers le haut on veut
arriver à travailler ensemble en bonne
intelligence
et ça je trouve que pour moi ça a été
une plus importante expérience de ma vie
dans ma vie professionnelle
alors je vais changer de balle et je
vais aller là une amie d'harry la vallée
de titane et vous appuyez t mac à 34,500
un projet dénommé prix mais le maître
des congrès de force et par les pros un
petit peu important mais là on était une
petite échelle
un peu comme dans la halle et paréo on
allait les propriétaires fonciers
bélarus bnf qui fait les agrégats le
greta
sur les chemins de randonnée on avait
une coopérative agricole nous laisse
développer faire du maraîchage dans les
vallées et on a essayé de se mettre à
parler pendant deux ans qui me disent on
a fait des centaines de réunions pour
arriver où le schéma est là comment
entre sur l'aspect maréchal nous
exploitons et les prix par exemple
l'obligation goûteurs défi c'est de les
entretenir en permanence assurée la
souplesse et nous valent donc ça permet
à des gens qui font ça pour du
maraîchage d'accès mais de manière des
mines et à des terres facilement ce qui
n'est pas faisable sur une activité à
faible valeur ajoutée comme donc la main
typiquement aujourd'hui les agriculteurs
qui sont qui sont installés on va
développer un sujet important pour le
fénoir montées sur des blindées
connaissons le développement de la
consommation
en parallèle à montabot disney qui sert
aussi bien un prestataire que aux gens
de la commune qui leur paraît d'aller
seul se balader passeport délivré des
écoles qui viennent un peu des sorties à
la journée des associations qui viennent
sa voix l'industriel c'est une vraie
réussite d'avoir au milieu d'un site
industriel et des enfants du clae loin
qui viennent se délient c'est vraiment
la chance depuis les balles et les
pulvérisations scientifique qui permet
de se balader à ces différentes c'est à
dire qu'en se baladant sa paire dead
hand et chaude sur la faune et la flore
ou la géologie les endroits où est ce
pas là un petit projet très ambitieux
mais nous en mettre plein la face aux
chinois une france entend souvent un peu
longue mais avec pareils volonté tout le
monde pour la table d'avancé naissance
j'ai fini à un petit peu peur depuis
elle a trois mois pour des raisons
professionnelles je me sens mieux et je
me suis dit qu'il est rare et valeo perd
de la vie je suis parti à la découverte
de la leopard la villa les traîtres
ce mobile est magnifique cascade superbe
la végétation luxuriante
c'est un vrai bonheur c'est aussi du
management concertée parce que
l'adduction d'eau trop tard ce qui fait
que ni pistes entretenues qui est ouvert
sur une grosse partie mois d'avril au
contenu c'est super la nature la verdure
en plein coeur d'alger mais un mec mais
metz et laval est hyper u et que le
panama qui permet malheureusement ça
ressemble pas à la partie vous aimez les
photos j'aurais pu faire plus que je
m'apprêtais à celle menant à midi et de
la soirée va dépêcher de marignane
bouches il aurait quasi assez cher il va
maintenir à terme ce que j'ai dit est
allé si vite et par leur niveau de la
mer et malheureusement je ne sens pas
encore visité de changer les choses
alors qu'on ait offert d'aller avec des
enfants qui savent pas quoi faire
mercredi après midi avec des gens qu'on
peut un marché regardez la forme
potentiellement tout est assez facile
d'accès c'est certainement un deal de
berville à nîmes
c'est typiquement salle paul j'aimerais
pouvoir changer et aussi parce que
l'arrêt des citoyens l on peut rire des
associations on est aussi des citoyens
dans la vie
voilà ce que j'espère que vous aurez
donné envie de vous intéresser
on a les mêmes et les lignes et puis que
dans dix ans on aura tout tourne à vide
et wallemme va se balader se faire
plaisir
notre plaisir c'est la dernière année
voilà merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]